cuando la mayoría de los ciudadanos
franceses esperaban que este domingo el
presidente manuel macrón a decretar a un
tercer confinamiento la sorpresa la ha
dado esta noche el primer ministro ran
castex tras participar de el cuarto
consejo de seguridad sanitario desde el
inicio de la crisis del cob y 19 francia
puede evitar el tercer confinamiento
dijo jan castex porque la situación
sanitaria es más estable que los países
los vecinos porque hace varios días se
mantienen las cifras 23.000 nuevos
contagios diarios cifras estables
también en los ingresos en reanimación
la única amenaza esta receta dijo castex
son las nuevas variantes del virus la
sudafricana y la británica por lo mismo
anunció otras medidas que poca gente se
esperaba el cierre de las fronteras
exteriores de la unión europea para
francia se prohíben los viajes hacia y
desde los países de fuera de la unión
europea incluido a los territorios de
ultramar franceses salvo por razones
imperiosas y para viajar dentro de la
unión europea se sigue exigiendo un test
psr la otra media importante el cierre
de los grandes centros comerciales que
no venden
porque el gobierno decide no decretar un
tercer confinamiento dicen que el
presidente está muy preocupado por la
salud mental de los franceses que no
podrían soportar un tercer confinamiento
también el elíseo veía con preocupación
lo que está pasando a los países bajos
donde las restricciones han sido
recibidas con manifestaciones muy
violentas y el ministerio de economía
también se oponía a un nuevo encierro de
la población 25 a 30 mil millones de
euros es lo que le cuesta un
confinamiento al fisco francés cada mes